ils ont à peine quelques jours pour la
plupart mais certains ont largement
passé l'âge de se retrouver dans une
maternité la vingtaine de nourrissons
n'a que ce sous sol etc infirmière
dévouée pour veiller sur eux et les
protéger d'une guerre qui a fait fuir la
majorité des résidents de ce quartier de
kiev où il se cache à les minimes aux
ministères amo bouten à l'ap nous
entendons les explosions mais nous
n'avons pas le temps d'avoir peur ces
petits anges nos appels il ya peut-être
des explosions mais ici il faut courir
changer des couches préparer des
biberons les bébés ne nous donne pas le
temps d'avoir peur
par dessus tout dit ludmila les nouveaux
nés ont besoin d'amour m'écouter débouté
national libyen kourina
bien sûr chacune d'entre nous aimeraient
être avec sa famille pour partager notre
2 commun notre catastrophe mais nos
familles comprennent très bien qu'on a
besoin de nous ici parce que ces enfants
ont besoin de soins spéciaux ils sont
ici sans parents alors ils ont
particulièrement besoin d'à montre
beauté brute le bruit tous ces enfants
sont nés de mères porteuses
leurs parents sont en europe en chine en
australie et au canada
depuis une vingtaine d'années l'ukraine
est devenue une destination de choix
pour la gestation pour autrui avec la
fermeture progressive de la thaïlande et
de l'inde en 2015 la pratique a explosé
ici environ deux mille bébés naissent de
mères porteuses chaque année en ukraine
elles seraient rémunérés jusqu'à 20
mille dollars américains pour leurs
services roche et kevin r porsche était
dans les premiers jours de la guerre la
première semaine c'était très difficile
de retenir les gens la panique est très
dangereuse
les parents biologiques ont essayé de
faire venir leurs mères porteuses à
l'étranger pour qu'elles accouchent là
bas mais il faut comprendre que dans la
plupart des pays européens la gestation
pour autrui est interdite et c'est
considéré comme du trafic humain
cela dit
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls problèmes
légaux auxquels doivent faire face les
familles les services d'état civil ne
fonctionne presque plus et selon la loi
en vigueur les familles doivent être
présentes en ukraine pour confirmer la
nationalité de l'enfant
or avec la guerre beaucoup de parents
n'arrivent pas à faire le voyage pour
venir chercher leur bébé mais certains
prennent encore le risque dit igor
piceno gars le directeur médical qui
fait aujourd'hui double emploi en
servant dans la réserve militaire pour
votre quand les parents arrivent à kiev
il ya des sirènes d'alerté partout mais
ils prennent leurs bébés dans leurs bras
avec les larmes aux yeux ils sont passés
par toutes les difficultés ils n'ont pas
pu avoir de la foire pendant 20 ans et
enfin ils en ont un un enfant c'est la
plus grande joie que vous pouvez avoir
d'autres familles ont recours à des ong
pour faire évacuer l'enfant qu'ils
attendent
niveau là en route pour gemini 3 selebi
charisme et citoyens canadiens notre
premier canadien
ne voit si harry huit jours emmitouflé
dans des vêtements chauds par ludmilla
juste avant son départ cette
organisation américaine a fait la route
jusqu à kiev pour ensuite conduire le
poupon à la frontière de la pologne où
il a pu rencontrer ses parents canal
vient pour la première fois
d'autres missions d'évacuation sont en
cours de préparation pour d'autres
familles au canada project d'un hameau
assure avoir reçu tout le soutien
nécessaire de l'ambassade canadienne
maintenant relocaliser en pologne
la mère porteuse du petit harry on ne la
voit pas ici en fait on ne voit aucune
de ces mères dans la maternité
improvisée de kiev
cette seule entreprise l'une des plus
importantes en ukraine affirme que près
de 500 femmes portent un enfant pour des
parents étrangers à l'heure actuelle 500
femmes pour qui le choix de fuir leur
pays en guerre n'en est pas un ici
marie-eve bédard radio canada qui